another great strategy that i like is
slack with a cost
another term for that is emergency
reserve but i don't like that term for
this because uh i don't see any need to
bring the term emergency into the mix i
just don't like what that does
psychologically
we're kind of replacing one
slightly disadvantageous term with
another there
so slack with a cost is great i also
like the idea of a calorie reserve
rather than an emergency reserve
but basically what you're doing with
this approach is you're setting an
ambitious goal for your calorie target
and your rate of weight loss we're
assuming it's a weight loss goal in this
context but it can theoretically be
applied in other contexts as well but
what you're doing here is you're setting
a calorie target for for each day but
you have this reserve of calories that
is there if you need it and it's
budgeted effectively so even if you use
it it's not like you're taking huge
steps backward it's like maybe a calorie
budget that puts you into a smaller
deficit but still a deficit for the week
or maybe it just brings you up to
maintenance for the week and you say
okay no steps backward but no major
steps forward that's totally fine but
you've got this calorie reserve and you
can tap into it as much or as little as
you want throughout the week and you can
allocate it throughout the week as much
as you wish so you might get to
wednesday and say
i for whatever reason today i'm using my
whole calorie reserve for the week you
use it up and then you get right back to
dieting you know there's been no no
explicit deviation from the plan you had
this reserve you used it no big deal um
and
if you wanted to you could also kind of
allocate it throughout the week or only
use part of it it's just there as it's
it's almost like an emergency fund with
finances where it's like i want to keep
that there just in case i need it and
sometimes i will have a financial issue
where i need to tap into that and use
some of it uh but the reason it's called
slack with a cost is because i think
this is actually
i think this actually effectively uses
some of those concepts related to
operant conditioning to some extent you
know we talked about how
you want to make sure that everything is
in alignment you don't want to have like
a reward that opposes your goal i like
the fact that slack has a cost here
which is that you can tap into it and
use it it's there to be used if you need
it but you understand that if you use
that you are slowing your rate of
progress toward the goal to some extent
it's not necessarily you know grinding
your progress to a halt but there is a
cost to using that emergency reserve uh
very
liberally and frequently and so you are
in this case instead of having this
weird incentive where you diet in in see
as you're seeking a reward of a cheat
meal that kind of opposes your goal you
have this reserve here but you
understand you know it's there if you
need it but as you use it more it is to
some extent going to slow you down a
little bit so you are incentivized to
only use it when you feel like you
really need it
so i think it better aligns that idea of
these extra calories that are actually
aligned with the incentives that match
your goal
so slack with a cost again a really
fantastic alternative strategy rather
than cheat meals